dans le cadre des rencontres de l'eau se
sont réunis dans l'hémicycle du palais
de la source le conseil départemental
l'office de l'eau ainsi que les
différents acteurs de l'eau des
rencontres organisées cette année autour
du thème regards croisés sur l'eau dans
les eaux une matinée d'échangés ainsi
que des réflexions menées collectivement
qui permettront d'aboutir à un véritable
plan d'action partagé pour
l'amélioration des conditions
d'alimentation en eau des eaux de l'ue
concernant donc l'alimentation
en haut des hauts de la réunion ou un
sidéen d'isoler c'est bien un problème
d'isolement c'est le cas de le dire ça
veut dire trouver la ressource en eau
parce que naturellement l'eau s'écoule
donc leur part du haut vers le bas
s'il n'y a pas d'eau qui tombent sur les
os on risque d'avoir des problèmes de
disponibilité de la ressource en eau ça
c'est une première problématique
la problématique c'est comment stocker
cette eau et comment amener cette eau
vers les activités qui en ont besoin
c'est très important de faire ce genre
de réunions parce que justement ça a
permis à la fois de d'identifier
probablement des méthodes des façons de
faire des connaissances qui sont quelque
part chez quelqu'un est de battre tout
ce monde ensemble ça permet justement de
partage et de mettre en commun toutes
ces méthodes toutes ses connaissances
qui permettront d'améliorer
l'alimentation en eau des saisons de
reculer depuis plus de 40 ans le
département s'investit dans le domaine
de l'eau et du développement agricole et
socioéconomiques de l'île dans le cadre
d'une politique de gestion globale et
solidaire la collectivité met en oeuvre
des moyens de satisfaction des usages et
besoins en eau du territoire les
branchements l'été ordinaire
institutionnel est très ancien dans le
domaine de l'eau puisque les
départements des livres de l'eau brute
déjà de penser les eaux d'irrigation on
prend le
basculement de l'eau de la cendre est ce
qui vient de se terminer donc c'était un
partenaire essentiel dans la délivrance
de l'eau brute
maintenant on a une problématique à la
réunion c'est d'alimentation en eau des
eaux de l'île nous avons des secteurs où
la ressource n'est pas suffisante
tout d'abord pour leurs thèmes de vos
tables ensuite pour les arts culture
ensuite pour le développement à vos
touristique et enfin pour
la larme colonisation dit puisque dans
certains secteurs les conquérir ne
discutait pas intervenir
donc il est très important de mettre en
place ce plan pour plus dans l'avenir ne
puisse améliorer l'alimentation en eau
pour tous les usages dans les eaux de
riz
les rencontres de l'eau constitue un
moment privilégié d'échangé de partage
et permettent de mener des réflexions
communes sur les enjeux en matière de
gestion de noms sur le bassin réunion